so given this diagram we need to figure
out what the length of cf right over
here is and you might already guess that
this will have to do something with
similar triangles because at least it
looks that triangle cfe
is similar to a b e and the the
intuition there is is kind of embedded
inside of it and we're going to prove
that to ourselves and it also looks like
triangle c f b is going to be similar to
triangle d eb but we're once again we're
gonna have to prove that to ourselves
and then maybe we can deal with all the
ratios of the different sides to cf
right over here and then actually figure
out what cf is going to be
so first let's let's prove to ourselves
that these definitely are similar
triangles so you have this 90 degree
angle in a b e and you're this 90 degree
angle in c f e if we can prove just one
other angle is or one other set of
corresponding angles is congruent in
both and we've proved that they're
similar and we can either show that look
they both show they both share this
angle right over here angle c e f is the
same as angle a
e b so we've shown two angles two
corresponding angles in these triangles
this is an angle in both triangles they
are congruent so the triangles are going
to be similar you could also show that
this line is parallel with this line
because obviously these two angles are
the same and so these angles will also
be the same so they're definitely
similar triangles so let's just write
that down get that out of the way we
know that triangle
a b e
a
b e
is similar to triangle c
f e and you want to make sure you get in
the right order
f is where the 90 degree angle is b is
where the 90 degree angle is so and then
e is where this orange angle is so c f e
it's similar to triangle c
f e now let's see if we can figure out
that same statement going the other way
looking at triangle d eb
so once again
once again you have a 90 degree angle
here if this is 90 then this is
definitely going to be 90 as well you
have a 90 degree angle here at cfb and
you have a 90 degree angle at d e f or d
e b however you want to call it so they
have one
set of corresponding angles that are
congruent and then you'll also see that
they both share this angle right over
here on the smaller triangle so i'm now
looking at i'm now looking at this
triangle right over here as opposed to
the one on the right so they both share
this angle right over here d
b e
angle dbe is the same as angle c b f so
so i've shown you already
that we have this
angle is congruent to this angle and we
have this angle is a part of both so
it's obviously course it's congruent to
itself so we have two angles two
corresponding angles that are congruent
to each other so we know that this
larger triangle over here is similar to
this smaller triangle over there so let
me write this down so we also know we
scroll over to the right a little bit
we also know that triangle
triangle d e b
is similar triangle d e b is similar to
triangle c f b
to triangle c
c f b
now what can we do from here well we
know that the ratios of corresponding
sides for any one of those each of those
similar triangles are going to have to
be the same but we only have one side of
one of the triangles so in the case of a
b and cfe we've only been given one side
in the case of deb and cfb we've only
been given one side right over here so
there doesn't seem to be a lot to work
with
and and this is why this is a slightly
more challenging problem here let's just
go ahead and see if we can assume one of
the sides and actually maybe a side
that's part that's shared by both of
these larger triangles and then maybe
things will work out from there so let's
just assume that this length right over
here let's just assume that be is equal
to y
so let me just write this down this
whole length is going to be equal to y
because this at least gives us something
to work with and y is shared by both a b
e and d e b so that seems useful and
then we're going to have to think about
the shorter the the short the smaller
chart the smaller triangles right over
there so maybe we'll call this length
we'll call bf
we'll call bf x
let's call bfx and then let's call fe
well if this is x and this is y minus x
so we've introduced a bunch of we've
introduced a bunch of variables here but
maybe with all the proportionalities and
things maybe maybe just maybe things
will work out or at least we'll have a
little bit more sense of where we can go
with this actual problem
but now we can start dealing with we can
now start dealing with the similar
triangles for example so we want to
figure out what cf we want to figure out
what cf is we now know that for these
two triangles right here the ratio of
the corresponding sides are going to be
costed so for example the ratio between
cf and 9 their corresponding sides
the ratio between cf and 9 has got to be
equal to the ratio
between
y minus x
y minus x that's that side right there
y minus x and the corresponding side of
the larger triangle well the
corresponding side of the larger
triangle is this entire is this entire
length and that entire length right over
there is y so it's equal to y minus x
over y
so we could simplify this a little bit
well i'll hold off for a second let's
see if we can do something similar with
this thing on the right
so once again we have cf
its corresponding side on d e b so now
we're looking at the triangle c f b not
looking at triangle c f e anymore so now
when we're looking at this triangle c f
corresponds to d e so we have c f
c f over de
is going to be equal to so cf over de is
going to be equal to x
is going to be equal to let me do that
in a different color
it's going to be equal to i'm using all
my colors it's going to be equal to x
over it's going to be equal to x over
this entire base right over here so this
entire be which once again we know is y
so over y
and now this looks interesting because
it looks like we have three unknowns we
have cf sorry we know what de is already
we this is 12. i could have written cf
over 12.
the ratio between cf and 12 is going to
be the ratio between x and y so we have
three unknowns and only two equations so
it seems hard to solve at first because
there's one unknown another unknown
another unknown another unknown another
unknown and another unknown but it looks
like i can write this right here this
expression in terms of x over y and then
we could do a substitution so that's why
this was a little tricky so this one
right here we can rewrite as
cf let me do that same green color
we can rewrite it as
cf
over 9
is equal to y minus x over y is the same
thing as y over y minus x over y over or
1 minus x over y all i did is i said
essentially i guess you could say
distributed the 1 over y times both of
these terms so y over y minus x over y
or 1 over or 1 minus x minus y and this
is useful because we already know what x
minus y is equal to
x sorry x over y is equal to we already
know that x over y is equal to cf over
12.
so this right over here i can replace
with this cf over 12. so then we get
this is the home stretch here cf which
is what we care about cf over 9 is equal
to 1 minus cf over 12.
and now we have one equation with one
unknown and we should be able to solve
this right over here so we could add cf
over 12 to both sides so you have cf
over 9 plus cf over 12 is equal to 1. we
just have to find a common denominator
here and i think 36 will do the trick
so
9 times 4 is 36 so if you have to
multiply 9 times 4 you have to multiply
cf times 4. so you have 4
cf 4cf over 36 the same thing as cfo
over 9 and then plus cf over 12 is the
same thing as 3
cf over 36 and this is going to be equal
to 1 and then we are left with
4cf plus 3cf is 7
cf
over 36 is equal to 1. and then to solve
for cf we can multiply both sides times
the reciprocal of 7 over 36 so 36
over 7 multiply both sides times that 36
over 7 this side things cancel out and
we are left with our final we get our
drum roll now
cf is equal to cf so all of this stuff
cancels out cf is equal to 36 1 times 36
over 7 or is just 36
over 7. and this was a pretty cool
problem because what it shows you is if
you have two things let's see this thing
is some type of a pole or a stick or
maybe the wall of a building or who
knows what it is if this is nine feet
tall or nine yards tall or nine meters
tall and this over here this other one
is 12 meters tall or 12 yards or
whatever you want units you want to use
it if you were to drape a string from
either of them to the base of the other
from the top of one of them to the base
of the other regardless of how far apart
these two things are going to be we just
said they're wide apart regardless of
how far apart they are the place where
those two strings would intersect is are
going to be 36 sevenths high or i guess
five and one sevens high regardless of
how far they are so that's a pretty i
don't know i think that was a pretty
cool cool problem